فضلا عن توترات موجودة بين بعض
الدول في الحلف قد تحول دون
اجماع خلال الحرب المتوقعة.
اعتبارا من عام الفين واثنين
وعشرين. كان لدى حلف الناتو ما
يقرب من ثلاثة ملايين وثلاثمائة
تذر. فماذا لو اندلعت هذه الحرب
برأيكم? وهل سيكون هناك طرف
الناتو الثلاثين هناك الكثير من
الدول التي ستنضم في طرف الناتو
بينما هناك دول مرعبة ستنضم بشكل
مؤكد الى الطرف الروسي. وهي
السويد على ذلك? المؤكد ان ذلك
يقود بشكل واضحا لحرب لن تكون
والخليجيون بين الطرفين بحسب
المصالح لكل الدول وهناك ستحدث
وكازاخستان وقرغيزستان
وطاجكستان. وسينقسم الغرب
باردة هذه المرة بين روسيا وحلف
الناتو. الامر الذي قد يجر دول
العالم الى الاضطرار للاختيار
بين الطرفين. فبالاضافة لدول
موسكو قد تضطر لاتخاذ اجراءات
جوابية حال انضمام البلدين الى
الصين عملاق اقتصاد العالم
وكوريا الشمالية بمجنونها كيم
مستقل خط سياستها الامنية تاركة
تهديدات روسيا خلفها. فهل تقوى
الحلف ترد فنلندا بقولها لقد
سمعنا هذا من قبل. وكانهم يتحدون
يعتبر الهجوم تجاوزا لاراض في
حلف الناتو. فما زالت الحرب ضمن
وروسيا لوحدها تمتلك اكثر مما
يمتلكه حلف مكون من ثلاثين دولة.
وزارة الخارجية الروسية عبر عن
قلق موسكو ازاء جهود الولايات
المتحدة وبعض حلفائها لجر فنلندا
والسويد الى الناتو، وحذر من ان
روسيا شنت هجوما فعلا في وقت
سابق على قاعدة عسكرية قرب
وايران وشيشان بمصارعها قديروف.
فضلا عن ارمينيا وبلاروسيا
الحرب? وقبل الاجابة فان ما هو
مؤكد انه لو اندلعت هذه الحرب
الحدود الاوكرانية البولندية وهي
ضمن حلف الناتو. لكن الغريب لم
واربعين. دول حلف الناتو متخوفة
في حال قررت موسكو رغم كل
الكارثة وستندلع حرب تبيد البشر
والشجر والحجر حرب لا تبقي ولا
الناتو. وتعد المادة الخامسة من
ميثاق حلف الناتو حجر الزاوية
البحرية مع الفين وتسع واربعين
سفينة عسكرية مقابل ستمائة وخمس
اربعة عشر الف ستمائة واثنتين
وثمانين للناتو. ارتفاع
لماذا يا هؤلاء? كل هذا من اجل
تدريبات فقط? قرار بدء المناورات
شأنه ان يؤدي الى عواقب عسكرية
وسياسية خطيرة. وكان بيان صدر عن
الناتو وسيكون ذلك فعليا اعلان
حرب ويا لها من حرب يخافها
التحذيرات اطلاق صواريخ تتجاوز
الحدود الاوكرانية الى دول
روسيا لكن قبل ذلك كانت روسيا قد
حشد اكثر من مائة الف من قواتها
التقليدية ورغم تكرار الامر ذاته
الان لكن على شكل اجتياح اوسع
اما ما يزيد التوترات اكثر هو
تجاهل فنلندا والسويد تحذيرات
التوترات. عندما اجتاحت روسيا
الحدود نحو اوكرانيا وضمت اليها
الحدود الاوكرانية لكن ذلك زاد
من حدة التوترات بين الطرفين.
على الاكتفاء بتقديم اسلحة
دفاعية الى الحكومة في كييف وفرض
دولة من اوروبا وامريكا الشمالية
يتدربون في درجات حرارة ما دون
روسيا من ان انضمامهما المحتمل
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي. الناتو من
شبه جزيرة القرن في عام الفين
واربعة عشر وقع حلف الناتو في
حيرة من امره بسبب حملة موسكو
العسكرية المفاجئة وغير
على حدود اوكرانيا. والناتو يحذر
ويكرر تحذيره من غزو وشيك
العالم ولكنه ينتظر ليعلم لمن
القوة والسيطرة في هذا العالم.
فيه. تتعرض لاعتداء منذ تأسيس
الحلف عام الف وتسعمائة تسعة
لروسيا. ومع ذلك فان المركبات
القتالية البرية الروسية اكثر
عقوبات على موسكو. وماذا عن
غروركم وكبريائكم يا اعضاء حلف
مقابل اربعة الاف ومائة وثلاث
وسبعين طائرة لروسيا وفي القوة
قدرة على المنافسة مع اثني عشر
الف واربعمائة وعشرين وحدة الى
لاوكرانيا فان حلف شمال الاطلسي
لم على التدخل بشكل مباشر وحرص
الصفر يجرون مناورات هي الاقوى
والاكبر منذ الحرب الباردة تسمى
للدول الثلاثين التي يتألف منها
الناتو ما تمتلكه روسيا من حيث
وسبعين الف فرد عسكري نشط مقارنة
بمليون وثلاثمائة وخمسين الف فرد
المعمورة. بلغت ميزانية حلف
الناتو في ديسمبر الفين وواحد
سلاح الردع النووي فترى سنة حلف
الناتو النووية المجمعة تبلغ ستة
وماذا لو اندلعت الحرب بينهما من
منهما سيكون الاقوى خلال هذه
عدد الطائرات مع عشرين الف
وسبعمائة وثلاث وعشرين طائرة
عسكري نشط في الجيش الروسي.
وتفوق القدرات العسكرية الجماعية
مائتا طائرة حربية ثلاثون الف
جندي وتشترك فيها ثمان وعشرون
ذلك الى اطمئنان ولو بشكل بسيط
لدى الناتو. لكن بعد ذلك وجهت
وعشرين نحو ثلاثمائة وثلاثة
وستين مليار دولار. فيما تبلغ
من شأنها زيادة التصعيد في
اوكرانيا. بينما يرد الغرب ان
لمن ستكون الغلبة؟ وما سيحدث
عندها؟ هل ستكون حربا عالمية
روسيا الضربة الكبرى وبدأت الحرب
ضد متجاهلة جميع تهديدات
تدريباتها المكثفة. وماذا بعد?
سحبت روسيا بعضا من قواتها. ادى
الاف وخمسة وستين رأسا حرب نوويا
مقارنة بستة الاف ومائتين وخمسة
فهي حرب عالمية ثالثة شاملة لن
يرغب بحدوثها احد على وجه هذه
المناورات قد وجدت من قبل الازمة
وهي تدريبات ليست بالجديدة على
ميزانية الجيش الروسي نحو مائة
واربعة وخمسين مليار دولار. اما
مع روسيا. قامت الدنيا ولم تقعد.
موسكو اعتبرت هذه المناورات حركة
روسيا على اما السويد فتقول انها
وحدها هي التي تقرر بنفسها وبشكل
ارض الواقع؟ وسط تأكيدات بان اي
مواجهة بين الحلف وموسكو تعني
الحرب ضد روسيا؟ الاستجابة
الباردة؟ خمسون سفينة حربية
لاوكرانيا. اجرت موسكو مناوراتها
على حدود اوكرانيا واكملت
التوترات بين الناتو وروسيا خرجت
المقارنات بين قوات الطرفين.
وتحضيرات حلف شمال الاطلسي
الناتو. قوة الجيوش. بعد كل هذه
والواقع شيء اخر. واشنطن تحذر
موسكو من تفعيل المادة الخامسة
الامريكية؟ وماذا سيحدث في هذه
المواجهة المحتملة ان حدثت على
جاء بعد اعلان موسكو الحرب على
كييف? الامر الذي يهدد السلام
مواجهة حلف الناتو الذي تتزعمه
بالاساس الولايات المتحدة
الاوروبي والعالمية برمته? نعم
كان مخططا لهذه مسبقا لكن توقيت
رائحة البارود تنتشر في الارجاء.
الجليد على وشك الانكسار وجبال
اندلاع حرب عالمية ثالثة؟ فماذا
لو قامت حرب بين الناتو وروسيا؟
الثلج تذوب وتتحطم. امريكا تحذر
وروسيا تهدد والنيتو يندد.
حقا؟ وما الذي تريده روسيا من
الناتو؟ ولماذا يتجنب حلف الناتو
فيه. لان فكرة الحلف تقوم على
الدفاع الجماعي عن اي دولة عضو
اجرائها سيعطيها اهمية كبيرة
خاصة انها تترافق مع توتر الحلف
وخمسين رأسا في روسيا وهو تفوق
واضح لروسيا. ارقام مرعبة ومهولة
ستجعل العالم في خبر كان. لكن
فيما لو اندلعت الحرب العالمية.
بمناورات الاستجابة الباردة.
لماذا كل هذه الاعداد الضخمة?
منتصر ام ان الخسارة ستشمل الكرة
الارضية باسرها?
من ميثاق حلف شمال الاطلسي.
الناتو. فما هي المادة الخامسة
من ميثاق الناتو? يفتح ذلك بابا
الحديث عن قدرات روسيا وجيشها في